um there is just so much misinformation
about arianism about the Council of NAA
in particular the Council of NAA like
one of again one of the most popular
things that we hear is that the Council
of NAA decided on the New Testament
cannon that that is when the books of
the New Testament and the Bible were
decided on and before that there were no
there was nothing of the sort this is
simply not true this Council messia had
nothing to do with this neither did the
Council of NAA come up with the Trinity
the idea of the Trinity and its basic
Futures existed before that but there
were different as we see different
perspectives on what the relationship
within that Trinity was that isn't to
say that everyone believed in a trinity
of course they didn't the gnostics don't
have the Trinity for example but but
many Christians already had that kind of
idea